so we were far forward in Helmand
province and to care a lot of gunshot
wounds and blast injuries and a lot of
really really devastating war wounds so
a lot of these guys that we took care of
you know we became really good friends
with over the years and we had put them
on opiates and benzos and
antidepressants and essentially turned
all these guys into zombies and so you
know I was like connected with a lot of
these soldiers over the years after they
they came back they they started coming
back and telling me that look we were
able to get off our opiates or we were
able to stop using our benzodiazepines
or antidepressants or you know because
we've started taking CPD and we've
started using cannabinoids you know
Israel is doing the idea they actually
allow their soldiers to use some of
these cannabinoids while they're still
active duty because because this stuff
works and they found that it works very
very well for PTSD for sleep disorders
for chronic pain you know and we we
really should start to be scheduled
cannabis and really start to allow our
soldiers to take it find a criminal that
we're keeping this this type of medicine
away from our veterans and and of course
the larger American public as well when
we have potentially
a solution that can that's not gonna
make them addicted you know that will
make them better functional human beings
that allow them to maybe connect with
their families again I just think it's
wrong that the VA and other federal
agencies don't allow soldiers for their
families to take this stuff multiple
multiple ways we have a farm and organ
that we grow organic in an organic way
hemp we've tested the soil we tested the
water make sure everything's all
wonderfully clean and then we test
everything again once we harvest it just
to make sure these you know organic
fertilizers so we so that's one way you
know we we have a large farm and we we
want to help grow the industry literally
but we want to do it in a responsible
way
I think the most beautiful thing in the
world is the human heart and just just
watching people to do wonderful
beautiful things I think all that stems
someone's opinion me contradict yours
why is my friend Alan it's all about
your perspective who are we and what is
the nature of this reality
[Music]
what's up everyone welcome to simulation
I'm your host Alan Sathyan we are on
site at the beautiful new West Summit
the cannabis tech conference we are now
going to be speaking with dr. Kamal call
see hello hello thank you so much for
coming on oh no pleasure really
appreciate him so come for this episode
thank you you are a doctor
a soldier sick a farmer an advocate I
mean there's your background is very
deeply nuanced and I'm super excited to
jump into this with you let's talk about
things from the perspective of your
journey who you are were we born
take us through things chronologically
Wow all right sure you know I mean I'm
an immigrant I came here when I was 2
years old I was born in in Kanpur Air
Force Base in India and a lot of a lot
of folks don't know what or who's six
are but sick Sikhism is the world's
fifth largest religion and we wear you
know very stylish turbans it's a part of
our identity and you know it's a really
interesting journey here here in you
know in the u.s. you moved when you were
2 - yeah woman I mean my parents came
and I they they brought me with them I'd
really didn't have much of a choice were
they both in farm forces at the time Oh
my father served in the Indian Air Force
India yeah my mom was a teacher there in
India and then they they came here my
grandfather also was in the Indian Air
Force my great-grandfather was in the
Royal British Army whoa yeah what a
lineage yeah so I in in med school they
when the recruiters came they wanted to
know if I wanted to serve and so I said
yeah I'm happy to serve but I serve like
this
with with turban and beard and this was
the this was nine sorry this was 2001
this is before 9/11 and I'm like yeah
man I you know I come from three
generations of military I'd be happy to
serve and so so I did I took an oath as
an officer in the US Army to defend and
protect the US Constitution and and
everything that we stand for and you
know I've been on active duty I served
in Afghanistan we treated hundreds of
combat casualties in a you know a what
they called it was a sort of a attended
er so we were far forward in Helmand
province and took care a lot of gunshot
wounds and blast injuries and a lot of
really really devastating war wounds and
so a lot of these guys that we took care
of you know we I you know we became
really good friends with over the years
and we had put them on opiates and
benzos and antidepressants and
essentially turned all these guys into
zombies and so you know as I connected
with a lot of these soldiers over the
years after they they came back they
they started coming back and telling me
that look we were able to get off our
opiates or we were able to stop using
our benzodiazepines or antidepressants
or you know because we've started taking
CPD and where we've started using
cannabinoids so it that was a real
eye-opener for me because I had never
heard of this
you know CBD before and so I started
learning about it I started learning
about cannabinoids
and I became a huge advocate and
you know I just started looking into the
history of this prohibition of cannabis
cannabinoids and you know I just didn't
make sense to me you know it's right now
cannabis is a Schedule one drug which
technically means that it has no medical
purpose and that it has a very very high
addiction potential and as you know as a
doctor I know that that's just
ridiculous and also you know I just want
to put a quick disclaimer out there that
you know I'm not here as a
representative of DoD or the Army or the
medical establishment you know so if I
say anything silly or stupid it's just
me but but yeah so just seeing my fellow
soldiers and the veterans take it and
it's just changing their lives I think
was was was eye-opening for me and so as
I started learning more and more about
cannabinoids I looked at what you know
Israel's doing in the IDF you know they
actually allow their soldiers to use
some of these cannabinoids while they're
still active duty because because this
stuff works and they found that it works
very very well for PTSD for sleep
disorders for chronic pain you know then
and we we we really should start to D
schedule
cannabis and and really start to allow
our soldiers to take it
how would a journey
okay so man so um so Sikhism started
right when when you were a child that
was also with the family as well yeah
yeah I mean I we've we've you know our
our family is all sick we Sikhism is a
monotheistic religion based out of what
is India today you know it's one of the
world's youngest youngest major
religions it's only five hundred years
old
but it comes out of what what is the
punjab region of india and you know the
six of spread all over the world the
defense minister of canada is a sikh CEO
mastercard Ajay Banga he is a Sikh you
know and so a lot of times we get you
know we get a lot of backlash for from
the terrorist attacks 9/11 you know and
and we people people call us by names
you know those you know I remember being
at a movie theater right after the 9/11
attacks and people would would call me
Osama bin Laden just stupid stuff and
just we had to deal with a lot of hate
crimes and hate speech after 9/11 and
and so it's been it's been tough you
know and we I've got a lot of wonderful
beautiful Muslim friends and so we we
never want to throw them under the bus
so I you know so I resist the urge of
you know when when we have an ignorant
person you know coming to me and trying
to you know throw through you know hate
speech at us you know because they think
we're terrorists or something you know
we don't we don't say oh yeah but we're
not you know Muslim or oh we're not this
or that because it's it's wrong to hate
any community
so we we've resisted that urge at least
most of us I think have resisted that
urge to throw the another community
under the bus and I think it's
unfortunate that you know the the world
we live in right now we you know the the
parts of the current administration
would love it if we you know demonized
immigrants you know or demonized Latinos
or demonized Mexicans you know saying
that they they send us rapists and and
murderers and stuff it's just ridiculous
if you look at if you look at the true
statistics even undocumented immigrants
that come to this nation have have a
crime rate less than the average u.s.
population you know the legal US
population so so I think there's a lot
of fear-mongering and in society right
now politics comes into play and they
just you know they they paint a
narrative which is not not accurate and
being a sink has been a major aspect of
you know who you've become in like kind
of like what you've then been able to
bring there are so many pillars of that
school of thinking that I think have a
major philosophical grounding in the
importance of treating each other with
dignity and respect treating this all I
could divine the experience that we all
get to be a part of and that's I think
why when you give us the story of you
being in in in in
in armed forces that you have a actual
deep empathy for other humans that are
going through process of getting injured
and then getting addicted to to
solutions that are actually really bad
band-aids yeah that have much better
solutions available that are currently
illegal yeah and so that's that's kind
of this what I'm seeing in who you are
becoming I think this is like your
unique it's really it's really tough you
know we I think the military is one of
those places where we just we give our
soldiers all these medications but those
medications aren't necessarily healing
them you know it's just numbing them to
the outside world it's numbing them to
their pain but it's also just not not
making them functional human beings and
I think if we can you know there is a
role for for some opiates yeah I mean
like for acute pain when somebody's got
a really bad fracture you know you you
know they're gonna want it's something
to take that beign away you know you're
not you're not gonna give them some THC
or CBD and say hey this is gonna take
take care of your pain or you're not
gonna do any sort of major surgical
procedure
you know without these these some of
these strong narcotics it has a place
but but for those people that are sort
of more chronically injured you know
putting them on opiates and benzos and
antidepressants for a long term I think
will also have some really serious side
side effects and consequences and in it
doesn't make them functional but the
people that I see that have been you
know taking cannabinoids for their
conditions these are good functional
human beings you know they're like
they're not like
they're not zombies you and that's you
know that at least that that's my
opinion and that's what I have seen that
these these soldiers these friends of
mine of the years they've had been able
to get off their opiates and then so is
that they they seem to be much happier
and much more well-adjusted it's hard
you know after you come back from Iraq
or Afghanistan or wherever you've served
it's it's hard reintegrating and
readjusting for a lot of soldiers and
yeah
but but cannabinoids seem to really help
with a lot of the problems that they
face take us to where we typically don't
get the opportunity to immerse ourselves
into what goes on we don't really get to
see what is going on with the military
out in these places and you were giving
us these instances of people coming in
with very very serious injuries and very
serious PTSD just things that need
serious healing and and in those
instances what remedies are provided are
actually you know that's a major
principle but also the principle even
prior to that is you know why are we
there and what are we doing there
and so yeah take us through your
thoughts around that yeah it's it's
frustrating because a lot as I think a
lot of soldiers go through that same
line of questioning you know when when
we deployed we didn't really you know we
we had a mission right you know and
especially as a medical team we knew we
were there to treat soldiers but why
were we
why were we really there
you know and I think a lot of people
still have those questions I don't think
we've really answered some of those
questions even now but but we were there
for each other and soldiers always have
each other's backs and so we and we
carry that with us our whole lives so I
you know I want to be able to be there
for our soldiers even even now in any
way possible and and so I find it I find
a criminal that we're keeping this this
type of medicine away from our veterans
and and of course the larger American
public as well but when we have
potentially a solution that can that's
not going to make them addicted you know
that will make them better functional
human beings that allow them to maybe
connect with their families again I just
think it's wrong that the VA and other
federal agencies don't allow soldiers or
their families to take this stuff
so there's a couple things here the
first one is that how does one then even
begin to work with a country that has
the largest military industrial complex
that has a lot of history of of going
and making interventions around the
world and attempting to understand and
maybe catalyze some sort of change
towards peace and towards harmony
towards love and understanding how does
that happen you know I think I think all
things happen for a reason you know and
I I firmly believe that if you know hemp
and cannabis are coming up now you know
that at a period in our history which
seems very very dark you know and in
some regards you know I think this this
plant has come about because it's time
it's time to you know for us as a
civilization to start to reintegrate
with this plant and all the benefits
that come with it I mean you're talking
paper and fiber and medicines and fuel
you know energy there's there's so much
you can do with with hemp I mean we can
get rid of our dependence on plastics if
we really wanted to you could replace it
replace all that with hemp and so the I
think the world needs needs this plant
right now and in the United States is
it's poised to become the largest have
producer I think in the matter of the
next five to ten years recently we heard
that China was also China is gearing up
and it's gonna be a race now you know
is-is-is but but us grown agricultural
products are go all over the world I
mean nobody can compete with American
farmers and you know our soil is amazing
it's clean
you know a lot of times when stuff comes
out of China you know very have a lot of
heavy metal contamination you know their
their stuff is not necessarily clean and
we've seen that time and time again with
a number of the products that we get
from there so I think there will always
be a good demand for you know American
grown agricultural products I love how
you said that if we really unleash this
hemp in cannabis revolution and we could
potentially even decrease our
interventionist military policy yeah
yeah you know it's it's gonna heal the
world I really do think so we because
we're fighting for resources you know
and when it comes down to it yeah we're
fighting countries are fighting each
other for resources
so if hemp can help provide some of the
energy and sometimes faith land yeah I
me and many other things recently had
the resources now but it also you know
if it's if it's medicine and it
decreases our health care costs you know
how how much are we spending on opiates
every year right I know where we're
generating more will be the addiction
how much does that cost yeah and and if
we can reduce that by even a fraction of
a bit you know we're we're doing so much
for the world and that's why I think you
know the benefit to the world is going
to be multifactorial and I think it's
gonna really start to help address some
of the major issues that we're facing
you know I think hemp could be one of
the techniques
one of the answers that we use to try to
combat climate change
you know if we're not cutting trees down
for paper and we're instead using hemp
fiber for paper it's so wonderful
renewable resource again where we're
starting to slowly heal the planet
together yeah that that vision is very
close to the heart it it will enable us
to find a greater amount of peace and
harmony together and I love how it
decreases the disputes over religion
over land over resources it has a lot of
consciousness awakening potential as
well to help catalyze those things that
we just listed yeah it's like a it's a
very spiritually ascending technology
and that um Oh
with the right like kind of like
indigenous ethos that night needs to
come with that though in order for it to
be treated that way yeah there's also
some cases of extreme the dichotomy to
that being like hyper recreational
escapism or whatever else it can and you
know that's I'm not judging those folks
I you know I think that there is a time
and place for four different things and
if some people want to use it
recreationally you know that works
totally fine and they there's they feel
like they need to do that you can go off
can far on that right but you know like
nobody's used as a substitute for
finding the meaning or finding the North
Star right life and then that is it
yeah yeah I mean but but nobody ever
dies from like you know cannabis you
know nobody's but you can get derailed
from your North Star trajectory if
you're not careful with the way that you
use it yeah absolutely you know and I
think there's an inherent danger
in using my mind altering substances you
know that you know you so I I personally
you know I I don't use cannabis or wheat
and I wouldn't want my kids to use it
you know but if you know if they need it
to use it medically then I think that's
totally fine you know and I you need to
use or if I need to use it medically I
would be totally fine with that and so
we you know get a non-psychoactive
compliance ISIF yes non psychoactive
yeah so THC is a lot of folks know or is
the psychoactive component to it one of
the psychoactive component strip but but
CBD alone does not doesn't make you high
you know and I know a lot of soldiers
that have told me that it helps them
fall asleep at night you know it they
can finally sleep without you know
having some of their nightmares helps
their PTSD is just you know it it's not
a panacea so it's not like you know you
can use it for everything but it but for
the things that especially soldiers face
I think it's it's bit it's it's pretty
good and let's talk about then all that
now so you know as you're here now new
West Summit and you come back from you
know being seeing first hand what is
being prescribed as band-aids rather
than the most optimal solutions being
able to leverage cannabinoids how how
are you doing your work in the industry
for that healing and assumption well
multiple ways we have a farm in Oregon
that we grow organic
in an organic way hemp we've tested the
soil we've tested the water made sure
everything's all wonderfully clean and
then we test everything again once we
harvest it just to make sure we use you
know organic fertilizers so we so that's
one way you know we we have a large farm
and we you know we want to help grow the
industry literally but we want to do it
in a responsible way and then I help out
with a brand called warfighter hemp
it's a CBD brand by veterans not just
for veterans but for everybody so half
of the profits from warfighter goes back
to veterans charities and I love that I
love their mission I don't make any
money from them but I I helped out that
as their scientific adviser so they're
good brand I know that it's it's clean
it's potent it is what they say it is
you know I I know I read our article
recently that a third-party company
tested a bunch of CBD and cannabis
cannabis products and half of them
didn't even have what they said you know
what the product labeling said it had so
you know I think the industry has a bit
of a problem and I I really do hope that
the industry will mature you know soon
because otherwise we're providing you
know products and you know it may just
be garbage and that's gonna turn
consumers off and that would be a shame
because this is you know it's a
wonderful product and we just need to be
as an industry a little more responsible
yeah and then do you also then have
within within what what the focuses are
right now there's 220 acres in Oregon no
ham industrial hemp it was a rough year
in Oregon I mean that I think it just
snowed in Colorado this earlier this
week and it was it's only you know it's
only October that's not normal
so Oregon has also been hit with some
cold weather and precipitation which you
know late in the season isn't isn't
really good for him so I know a lot of
farms I mean where we're sort of lucky
but a lot of farms and work and I've
just been devastated so we you know we
feel for them it's not easy to grow this
stuff it's it's a you have to have you
have to have some experience and you
have to know what you're doing
I know a lot of folks left the cannabis
industry to start you know as soon as
the farm bill passed and they set up
we're gonna just grow hemp and make
millions of dollars but it's not quite
that simple it's it it is quite
difficult to grow in in some respects
and you have to have some some knowledge
there and then this is all for sale as
well on your yes yeah yeah so we're
definitely looking for buyers for our
biomass so we'll probably have like
three hundred thousand pounds of
industrial hemp to sell and we'll have
to likely move that in the next month or
two Wow Wow
and then war fighter or fighter war
fighter hand
yeah or fighter huh which that's -
that's the the brand that I help out you
know a good good bunch of veterans good
guys just just trying to you know do
some good in this world and that's
through education and then through
delivering the actual product yeah yeah
yeah yeah there it's a certified organic
product and very potent I mean they make
a 6,000 milligram bottle and so each of
the doses there is 200 milligrams so
very potent we've had a lot of really
wonderful success stories with veterans
and non-veterans taking it for a variety
of conditions sometimes their cancer
patients or sometimes their folks that
just have chronic pain from their
injuries and and so if you go to the
website at warfighter have comm you can
read you know the you know hundreds of
testimonials from you know from the
folks that take warfighter happened it's
a it's it's really nice it's really nice
to be helping folks out like that and
it's as a substitute for yes yeah that's
a straight up substitute and also as a
healing mechanism for PTSD and okay Wow
so physical injury psychological trauma
yeah how many people would you say right
now our coming home
from war the military with serious
physical injury or psychological trauma
and how many are getting are you guys
onboarding onto a warfighter have been
yeah well well the so the VA and the
military system doesn't quite allow or
advocate for any cannabinoid right now
including CBD now if you're taking a CBD
isolate that doesn't have any THC in it
and should be okay but but you know it's
something that you probably would want
to talk to your command about or at
least your your doctor and see and make
sure that they're okay but yeah it's
it's you know I think I think every
soldier that comes back from a
deployment has some degree of injury you
know be it either physical or
psychological and it may not be
clinically significant you know some
people can deal with their their PTSD
very well because they have an excellent
support system you know my my family a
huge family and before I deployed you
know they dropped everything you know my
my parents my wife and they just they
came down and they spent a week with me
at Fort Polk in Louisiana it's not
really a whole lot down there but but
but they spent a week down there just
before I deployed just to be there with
me and then you know what I was came
back they were all there for me so I I
know that a lot of folks don't have that
type of a support system Wow so that's
why I know a lot of a lot of soldiers
have a really really hard time you know
with that reintegration piece so we're
we're hoping that we will be able to
someday work closely with the VA and you
know the military as an institution to
try to get this stuff into soldiers
hands and what is the roadmap for
something like that it's gonna take time
you know I I want to say something like
five to ten years maybe just for CBD
alone and then an who needs to be talked
to for this you know the the the the
director of the VA you know the and then
the Chiefs of Staff of each of the
agencies you know for the Army for the
Navy for the Marines and the Coast Guard
the Air Force all of them need to be on
board and unfortunately in the Pentagon
a lot of these guys that are in charge
of these services are you know they're
in they're in their sixties they're
older folks and they just think when
when they think cannabis they think of
somebody you know smoking you know
a big blunt so the most folks these days
especially in places where it's
legalized like over 80% of the public is
taking it as a as a consumable yeah like
in Louisville as you know and as an oil
they're taking using it as a tincture so
I think there's a lot of misconceptions
misconceptions a lot of ignorance about
how lobbyists that have pushed for
certain agendas that yeah break through
the VA is probably one of the biggest
clients of the pharmaceutical oh my gosh
yeah I mean you can't imagine the amount
of opiates and other narcotics that are
prescribed through the military and the
VA system you know that losing that
would be you know be huge
and so there I am sure our lobbyists
that are pushing pushing on those
elevates to to not allow any sort of
cannabinoids well this seems like a
inevitable emergence and
to have the old code die faster so that
the new code can come in and do the
healing that it needs to do and save the
lives it needs to save and enable more
time with the families more creative
time is very very important what a young
I won't I wasn't saying I think you know
we we sometimes like to beat up on the
current administration or some folks too
but but the current administration did
pass the current farm bill I mean and
that did did legalize hemp so I think we
we do we we should the current farm bill
legalized the growth of hemp and
industrial industrial have naturally
Natalie yeah nationally federally
mmm-hmm
the current administration did yep well
this is something that hopefully
hardcore people that are against
Michigan can hopefully see as something
beneficial yeah it's something that
positive that that's positive that's
come out you know and there's you know
big big Republican politico's that that
have invested in in hemp and CBD I know
that a number of senators and Republican
congressman as well as Democrats that
have both started investing in hemp so
we you know I I think this is not really
a partisan issue it's not really a blue
a political issue in that regard this is
really just a health issue
yeah and it's a public health issue we
public health issue and a spiritual also
absolutely
yeah so we do really just need to open
the doors here and and allow our public
access to it Wow
such a great way to put it in that same
sort of mentality is how we've as we've
been interviewing people from maps and
multi-display association for
psychedelic studies we've also been
talking about as a public health issue
as a spiritual issue yeah that um that
seeing it that way is gonna is gonna
help a lot in education around that for
the world's very very important to begin
seeing it that way and hopefully we can
distribute content that helps people
yeah see it that way where do you see
this emerging market of cannabis and
hemp and then the way that every single
emerging market pride or that has pretty
much emerged where fruits are mostly
allocated towards the top percentages of
people that come in and invest yeah
versus how does this one have fruits
that become democratized and distributed
yeah I don't think that's gonna happen
mm-hmm
I just I don't where we are we are a
capitalist nation you know and sometimes
we are more capitalist than we are
democratic and I think that today's day
and age is a good reflection of that so
I think the cannabis industry and the
CBD industry much like many others will
start to grow rapidly once large
corporate players get involved and
that's just sort of the reality of the
situation now igni I'll give you a good
example like me as a small hemp farmer
220 acres sounds like a lot but it's
really it's it's nothing
once these big corporations come in you
know they're gonna grow like 2030
50,000 acres and they're gonna you know
they're gonna dominate the market and
you know little little guys like us what
are we gonna do we're just you know so
grow for ourselves yeah yet grow for
ourselves but these corporations are
gonna make a ton of money over this and
in it I just don't see any way around it
now they're still gonna be doing good
right because they're still they're
still bringing this plant to market
they're you know still bringing it to
the masses we'll hopefully still see a
ton of innovation using em you know
getting rid of regular plastics and
using hemp you know have based plastic
or bioplastic as a substitute and so all
all these industries will start to
develop so you know the corporate
capitalist model it isn't all evil it is
it it has a place in in the ecosystem
but I don't and I could be wrong but I
just don't see this industry becoming
sort of democratic as a industry where
the the little people will get to make
tremendous amounts of money from it this
is one that this one and blockchain
crypto to centralization tech I hope
those two as they emerge and this one
with cannabis and hemp also a lump in
the psychedelic and do genic renaissance
into it as well I hope these two
emerging markets do what the previous
emerging markets were not able to do
which is then distribute the fruits well
and you're right there will be a lot of
important capitalistic investing to move
things along and innovation that happens
is fantastic
yet we are very more and more is
pointing towards if people are not
inclusively
stake holded
to the process of the progress of
society there will be more issues that
come up so and you make a really great
point there you know I think if we
simply concentrate wealth at the very
top you know where we're going to end up
destroying this experiment it's not it's
not sustainable for the long run and the
only way we can sustain this is if we
can sort of have more equality in in the
way this business is done and handled
and have more quality and in the
offerings you know so so we you know as
it as a nation I think we need to take a
hard look at our capitalists tendencies
and figure out how to open up those
opportunities to to communities and
people that have not traditionally been
able to access them you know and I think
that's a you know the the inner cities
and some of these really poor
communities I think their way there
should be a way for the government to
come in and say hey you if you want to
open up a business or if you want to you
know if you want to become a hemp farmer
or something else you know we can help
you do that and I I think we the
government owes us that you know that Oh
is the people that because the creation
of opportunity potentially if the
government's already going to be growing
so much industrial here maybe they can
give the opportunity to people that are
historically unable to partake in it
yeah also there's just the microfinance
revolution happening so people can
potentially put in just ten or 100 or
thousand bucks into the
the big pots of the multi-million dollar
project so hopefully the regulations can
use frameworks as well can evolve in
absolutely and it's gonna take it's
gonna take some time but I would much
rather I would much rather give
downtrodden communities and an
opportunity to you know to be a part of
this industry and make make some money
rather than just give them you know
money you know just you know that I
think government programs are great and
I think there's you know they have some
utility they have a lot of utility but
meaning every day is higher under the by
yes yeah and I you know I've had friends
and family that have you know had to go
to the they've been laid off and had to
rely on on you know government and
assistance just to make it make it by
make it through and it's not a good
feeling you know nobody wants that you
know nobody wants nobody's sitting there
and saying oh yeah we're we're sitting
in the den of luxury with this
government handout you know which is
it's a measly sum it's not it's not
making anybody rich and we need to
really help these communities in a in a
more meaningful way and help uplift them
through through business and commerce
the two questions that we typically ask
at the end of the show to our guests
is do you think we are in a simulation
are we in a simulation we was definitely
in a simulation oh I think when when you
look back on ancient philosophies you
know you could take any tradition you
know they tell you and I could tell you
at least from from the sick perspective
we're told that this is this is not this
is not reality that there is that there
is another layer to this something else
and it's not necessarily heaven or hell
it's just that there is something
there's something behind this this this
there's a veil there's a veil and we
were piercing it with our consciousness
awareness increasing yeah some do some
some can but I think we as as a whole as
a humanity need to definitely start to
maybe a lift the veil a little bit yes
and you know I don't know if it's a
computer simulation maybe it's some sort
of a natural simulation maybe there's
another dimension beyond this I think
quantum physics says that there
potentially 11 different dimensions or
twelve I don't know they keep change the
stream of URIs yeah so okay I've got
there yeah the question what do you
thinks the most beautiful thing in the
world
it's my wife watching my wife she's not
a thing I think the most beautiful thing
in the world is the human heart and just
just watching people do do wonderful
beautiful things you know I think all
that stems from from from the heart a
hundred thousand beats a day yes
incredible it is and there's kind acts
of love and yes yeah come on pleasure
thank you thank you so much what an
incredible conversation thank you thank
you for all your great work thank you
thanks everyone for tuning in we greatly
appreciate it would love to hear your
thoughts in the comments below on the
episode let us know your thinking check
out the links in the bio below to come
all's work also check out links of bow
below it's a new West Summit check out
the links of bow bow to our show as well
help support all of us help us continue
doing cool things like coming here for
powerful interviews of leaders also go
and build the future everyone manifest
your dreams into the world we love you
very much thank you for tuning in and we
will see you soon peace also great job
thank you that was I hope it's
interesting for folks it was really
great thank you thank you thank you we
did a great job I had a great time yeah
I did too good I'm so glad to hear that
alright let's get you to Mike
[Music]